que la saison des fêtes tendance avons
nous des traditions usa
je regrette amena c'est ma faute si nous
n'avons pas de tradition familiale
mais je pars aux missions pour rapporter
au royaume de la plus belle des
traditions
tu m'auras nous feront du porte-à-porte
recherche des traditions familiales nous
préparons des sucres d'orge wbc poncet
s'est créé si j'ai bien compris vous
abattez un arbre et vous décorer son
cadavre avec des bougies
c'est magnifique l'entrée par effraction
et autorisé le jour de noël aux regards
deviennent avec regret des bons jours
auquel berbie adam entier
on va leur trouver les meilleurs avis
sur des morts
à
les autres ont fait du bien de se
détendre et en un an
baby one la classe je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé en sommes tous ensemble le
bonheur
pour cent